welcome to the sphere I'm just started
the game five minute get smoked y FM
from from the UK and we have a sloth
defense let's see what specific line I
is taking on c4 is there something else
I could play a while a four is probably
almost mandatory yeah let's play 95
usually I player 3 but III but why not
do this for change 95 and an 85 right
the socal of variation yeah yeah how did
how do they play that f3 is ambitious
but unclear if it's really a great I
think you can go g3 ya head I've studied
this line I had studied the slide some
some years ago for black and considered
it quite quite okay but I really have
forgotten the real fine real finer
points I knew that or I remember that
this some kind of setup that I'm just
playing what's quite ok for what just
being just being solid and expand
expanding in the center slowly
you know does he play five are probably
not that's just a complete development
if I they have d5 just complete don't
think that's so great ready ok ok he's
immediately going for those weaknesses
this is of course this is of course
interesting but if i take here let's see
I don't really am I don't really
understand at the moment what he's doing
if i take here what is the big point of
threatening 95 if not just the porn it's
95 95
that's that's the real point of the 95
move I can take twice on before takes
takes should before but this rocks is
6mm let's sir let's consider for a
moment
maybe just this one and now Bishop b5
covering the d3 square they are still
before hanging and it's not easy head
auto protected young but still be sure
before setting setting up this pin or
evade it looks like a very loose
position I hope I'm not blundering
something all my pieces aren't protected
be for c1 and d5 this this can easily be
a something that backfires on I can take
c5 Roxy 5 rupee a check black resigned
yeah well this was strange i don't i'm
not i'm not sure i know i mean ii 5v5
looks mistimed the compounds to play
Knight f6 and considers black to be okay
as possible but let me just I want to I
want to make sure that this technical
stuff is not working really let's let's
check i took takes take so I'll add the
compass giving me a winning edge that's
reassuring but this is really okay your
Bishop compounds to play Bishop before
it takes on before with the night maybe
this is this is even better perhaps but
it's it's quite okay I'm a porn up
already and before it's basically gone
while you get into this this stuff which
is also not good yeah computer proofs of
all moves that's good yeah but black
should do is probably just further
improve pieces like like your naughty
five
like rock da truck cañada maybe you
could drop the bishop back night a
six-night be 8 a-6 before do you
basically keep your structure compact
and hope that white will also extend at
some point white should only slowly
advance pawns and gain more space make
sure that you're not weakening yourself
and this is a very complex game rising
wear black needs to be a patient the way
it went down um with d5 he really had to
play this comp defense Knight f6 takes
and Bishop h5 Edison see obviously
hadn't intended the ideas that after
additional three you can take and play
me for in order to recapture next movie
this is some a playable position for
black alright thanks for watching